[Music]
what's up you guys doing another tomes
of terror
today we're doing kind of like i guess
this is sort of like a classic
it came out in 1983. you know a horror
classic gothic classic
especially british gothic if you're a
fan of british horror
and gothic fiction in general you may
have already read this but i had
actually not um i'll get into that in a
moment but this
is the woman in black
by susan hill this is an interesting
one i put i picked this in particular
just because
one it gets recommended all the time um
you know by people that are like oh the
scariest ghost stories or whatever
and i really like classic ghost stories
i really like gothic fiction i really
like british ghost stories in particular
and i had seen both film
adaptations of this book so i was really
kind of interested to
you know read the source material and
see how much it differed
now because of that um i am going to
discuss the movies a little bit just in
the sense of like how they were
different from the book
so this uh actually may have some
spoilers
but i will like warn you before i spoil
anything like before i talk about like
the differences in the ends of the
book and the movies and stuff um i
actually had a recommendation from
one of our listeners that i should
probably
you know just kind of talk about the
book review the book and then after a
certain point like warn everybody and
say hey there's going to be spoilers
after this point if you want to read the
book
because it is kind of like it does kind
of hamstring you a little bit when you
can't really talk about like major plot
points in the book
you know maybe if you want like a deeper
discussion of it
so i think i might start doing that from
here on out
i wanted to do it with this book in
particular just because
i feel like this book may be somewhat
more familiar than some of the other
ones i did not only because it's older
but also because it's been adapted so
many times
and i think most people particularly you
know in the uk are probably fairly
familiar with the story even if they've
never read it
so i don't think it'll hurt anything too
badly if i spoil some stuff but like i
said i will warn you ahead of time
before i do that so that said let's talk
a little bit about
uh the story now uh as i said most
people are probably familiar with it but
in case you were not
this is basically set in um i guess it's
sometime in the
late uh late 19th century early 20th
century
i want to say around that time around
the turn of the century
maybe a little later not really sure um
there is a
young solicitor at a firm and his name
is arthur kipps i believe he says he's
26 years old
and um he has uh you know an upcoming
marriage he's engaged to his uh
girlfriend stella and he's very excited
about that and he's kind of a junior
partner in a law firm
run by mr bentley so he's kind of
looking for
an assignment that's kind of gonna you
know show mr bentley that he has what it
takes to be partner
like at least get a raise or something
like that so he can get married and you
know they can have like a decent life
together
so the first big assignment that he is
given
he gets sent to settle the affairs of
this woman
uh mrs drablow now she was a widow
and she has just died in this rather
remote
town because arthur kips you know he
lives and works in london
so it's kind of this remote like market
town called krithin gifford
which i don't know i don't think that's
a real town but correct me if i'm wrong
i've never heard of it before
it sounds welsh but so basically mrs
drablow who was kind of um very
reclusive
she was the client of the um of this
law firm where arthur kipps works and
she has passed away
so arthur basically has to go
to the town where she lived and go to
her house
and go through all of her papers and if
he finds anything of significance he has
to send them back to you know he
basically like i said just has to settle
her affairs because that's kind of what
the solicitor does
so he kind of looks forward to this like
oh it's like a big assignment he doesn't
think it's gonna take
very long you know it's like oh a few
days in the country it'll be nice to get
out of
you know all the smog and all the noise
and stuff like that in london
so he says goodbye to his um fiance
stella
and gets on the train and heads off to
this tiny little town
now while he's on the train he meets
this guy named samuel daly
who seems to know something about the
town but
is sort of cagey about it and that's
kind of another thing that happens a lot
in this book is that
even when he gets to the town the people
in the town aren't necessarily
hostile um and as a matter of fact like
the couple that owns like the
inn where he stays at first are actually
very friendly and very welcoming
but when he asks people like about mrs
drablow like oh you know i heard she was
kind of reclusive and
all this other kind of stuff people kind
of clam up a little bit like they don't
really want to talk about it so it's not
so much hostility as everyone's just
kind of like
you know and this like they don't want
to talk about it so we figure something
weird is going on but you know
he's very young he's very ambitious this
is his first big job he doesn't want to
mess it up
and he basically just thinks oh it's a
bunch of small town silliness it's like
this
won't take long it'll be fine you know
he's just
is going on with it and he doesn't
really think anything of it
so it ends up that he gets taken out
well first thing
first he has to go to mrs drable's
funeral
which not a lot of people show up at and
a little bit of a weird thing happens
there
where he sees across the cemetery this
woman
uh who's wearing like a black dress like
morning clothes but like i said
it's not too weird because it's a
funeral sure um but also she's kind of
like
weird looking like she has some she
looks like she has some kind of like
wasting disease like she's very pale and
she looks very skeletal
um he doesn't think of it as a ghost
necessarily but he just thinks oh it's
just
this mourner and it's like she kind of
stayed well back from everybody
um and he also like he sees her in the
church as well and then he sees her at
the cemetery but she always kind of like
when he goes to look for afterward to
find out who she is and maybe she's a
relative or something
he can't figure out where she went so he
ends up asking
this uh other solicitor that lives in
the town
uh mr jerome he's like so uh what was
the deal with that woman with the black
clothes on that i saw in the church and
at the funeral and stuff and he's just
like
i have no idea what you're talking about
and but honestly you know obviously he
does know what he's talking about
because he's like
[ __ ] his pants pretty much so he's
like huh that's odd
so he thinks it's weird but that you
know again he doesn't really think
anything of it so then he ends up having
to go out
to mrs drablow's house which is now
empty now many of the people in town and
he meets up with samuel daly again who
it turns out
uh was kind of like a wealthy merchant
he's like a landowner and stuff and he
lives around there and they kind of
become friends a little bit
most people are saying you know no one's
ever going to buy that house they're
going to buy the land that it's put on
because everyone's
kind of implying that it's like there
was something unsavory or you know but
although they do say that
well the land is not really any good
because like a farming community this
you know it's the land is not good for
farming on because basically
it's in the middle of a marsh so this
house is called eel marsh house and now
i did bring this up
when i was talking about the michael
mcdowell book the
the elementals i don't know if this is
where he got the idea
from because i think these books came
out like in a similar because i think
that one came out in the 80s too or
maybe even a little earlier
but it's kind of the same thing where
eel marsh house is just this
single house and it's sitting out on
this little slip of land like pretty
much in the middle of a marsh like
there's like an estuary
and then there's just this big marsh and
there's nothing else around so it's just
this house and nothing else
and you can only go to this house at
when the tide is out because there's
this causeway called the nine lives
causeway which i love
you know the rest of the time it's like
underwater so only when the tide is
out can you get out to the house or come
back from the house and as i said
no one really has any reason to go out
there um no one has even been out there
for a while like people haven't even
seen
mrs drablow in in the many years like uh
you know
prior to her dying she'd been like kind
of a recluse out there so no one has
even like knew what she was up to
so basically he goes out there um he
gets taken out on this like pony and
trap
by a dude named kakwick who also seems
to know
some [ __ ] about the town and about the
house and stuff but keeps mom about it
like
mostly everybody in the town does so
arthur gets to this house and very
quickly begins to realize that this was
going to be a way bigger job
than he thought it was going to be
because there's just papers everywhere
and he's like most of them are probably
useless or probably nothing
but to get the job done correctly he has
to go through
every single thing and make sure that
nothing of importance gets thrown away
so he basically like sets to work now
when he first gets there though
he notices because like it's really
creepy like the whole um description of
the house is like really really creepy
because
you know basically you're in kind of
like i'm assuming i think this is like
the northern part of england somewhere
like
near the coast and there's this estuary
and so when it's
like stormy or cloudy outside he's like
basically you can't
see like where the ground ends in the
sky begins because it's all just gray
because it's all just water and stuff so
basically you have this impression of
just how
this house sitting out like in this
foggy nothingness and i think there's
like a really good
i mean the atmosphere like the
description of that is like really
really evocative and like really cool
so while he's at the house the first
thing he sees the woman in black
again and at this point even though he's
still
kind of trying to feel like well that's
got to be a person
because he said it looks like a person
because it doesn't look like a ghost it
looks like a solid
woman but she keeps like disappearing
and he's like look i don't think that
there's any other houses or any other
place where this
person could be coming from um you know
because the causeway was
at underwater at this point and also he
starts to feel
like when he sees her he starts to he
starts to feel all these overwhelming
emotions like rage and hatred and it's
really starting to like freak him out
a little bit so he kind of starts to
come to the conclusion that maybe
something supernatural is going on
now in spite of that and in spite of the
fact that he got
pretty freaked out he does you know want
to do his job to the best of his
abilities because as i said he's trying
to get a raise he's trying to get more
money
so he really wants to not mess this up
even though he has some
misgivings about staying there because
it's kind of a creepy place
he's like well you know i don't want to
be here for like a whole week
so i'm going to have to stay in this
house
overnight because it will be quicker i
won't have to come back and forth
with the tides and have to have cat
quick like bring them back and forth on
the pony and trap
and blah blah so he's like so i'm just
gonna stay overnight in this house
and try to sort through all these papers
as quickly as possible so i can get the
[ __ ] out of this town
because as i said everything seems a
little weird
in the place like i said not hostile
necessarily
but everyone's just kind of like real
buttoned up and no one will really tell
him anything about what's going on or
tell him anything about
mrs drablow or you know who that woman
might be or anything like that
as time goes on he ends up staying in
the house i believe he stays
at least a night or two one night he
actually gets stuck there because
he's kind of like having a freak out and
then the tide comes back in and it's
like there was a storm and so the
causeway wasn't you know it didn't come
back and so the guy had to
like come back and get him at like two
or three in the morning or whatever so
while he's staying at this house
samuel daly who he has befriended as i
said he met him on the train like coming
to the place
at the beginning of the book he actually
loans him a little
dog like a little terrier named spider
like to keep him company
him in spite so arthur and spider like
are hanging out at this house and um
all kind of like real creepy like pretty
standard haunted house stuff starts to
happen
there's like creaky noises he starts um
seeing there's like a there's a room in
the house that's like all the rest of
the rooms can open but it's like this
one that won't open
and he keeps hearing this weird like
thumping noise coming from within there
um he starts just like having these real
terrible emotions like he feels like
there's some big like overpowering rage
or
whatever so he starts to get like super
freaked out by it samuel daly ends up
saving him
and at this point samuel daly finally
tells him what the deal is with eel
marsh house
now as i said if you do not want to know
what the secret of the house is or what
was going on or who the ghost is or
anything like that
then please click off now because i'm
probably gonna spoil the rest of the
story
so just go read the book it's actually
very short i would
it's barely i think it's like a novella
i think my this edition here that i have
um i believe is only like 154 pages i
want to say or something like that 100
or okay 164 pages i almost got it right
but yeah so it's like novella length you
can read it like in an afternoon very
easily
so uh samuel daly finally tells him and
actually arthur kipps had started to
put some of this together himself just
from like some letters and some death
certificates and stuff
because one other thing that he heard a
couple of times that he thought was
probably
it seemed to like affect him a lot more
than the seeing the woman in black did
because like i said she didn't look like
spectral or anything she just looked
like a person
but he starts hearing these horrible
noises of
a pony and trap going into
the marsh like sinking into the marsh
and
hearing like a horrible like
heart-rending
child scream and he he's like it sound
ver
sounded very much like a pony a trap
going into the marsh and like you know
getting sucked down into the mud and
like drowning everyone that was in it so
he heard that a couple of times and it
really really wigged him out as it would
um even though you couldn't see it
because it was just so foggy so
he has found some death certificates
he's found some letters and what they do
is they piece together that mrs drablow
the last woman that lived in the house
um that has recently died
her sister she had a sister that had a
little boy
named nathaniel now because the sister
whose name was uh janet because she was
unmarried
um and that was a big no-no back then
couldn't have kids out of wedlock
so basically nathaniel had to be adopted
by mrs drablow and her husband now
janet allowed this at first because she
was just kind of like okay because she
knew
she saw like the necessity of it but
after a while it seemed like mrs drablow
was like yeah i don't think i want you
seeing your kid anymore don't come here
anymore
and so there was like a bunch of um you
know family conflict like over
you know her getting to come see the kid
finally
uh mrs drablow whose first name was
alice i believe she relents
and she's like okay well you can come to
the house and stay here and
see your kid but you were not allowed to
ever ever
tell him that you're his real mom
those were the conditions uh that she
you know lived there and actually got to
see him so as it happened and again
spoiler alert spoiler alert spoiler
alert so i'm not warning you again so
what ends up happening is that nathaniel
and his
nurse uh as well as the driver of a pony
and trap and the pony too sadly
they were coming back from somewhere and
uh they indeed the pony and trap
were became lost in the fog and all of
them drowned
in the marsh and janet was
standing in the upper window and saw the
whole thing happen
and so after she died basically
her ghost who is the woman in black that
we've been seeing um she died of like
some wasting disease
hence why her ghost looks the way it
looks um she was so
filled with rage and anger she blamed um
her sister she blamed pretty much the
whole town
for you know doing this injustice upon
her tape like making her seem like she
had to take had her have her kid taken
away
and uh and then he ended up dying and
drowning and she watched it all happen
and was kind of helpless to prevent it
so now her ghost serves as a sort of
bad omen so every time that she's seen
in the town and you don't find this out
until like the last few pages of the
book
that means a child is going to die
she's like an ill omen so every time you
see her which is why
uh when arthur first sees her
like in the church in the cemetery like
at the beginning of the book at mrs
drabler's funeral
which is why mr jerome acts that way
because it turns out that mr jerome who
was the other solicitor who lives in the
town
the last time that the woman in black
was seen it was his i believe his
daughter
that ended up dying that's how that ends
up happening um
and basically the end of the book and
this is kind of interesting and like i
said i'll get into like the film
adaptations as well because i thought it
was some of the changes that they made
were kind of interesting
so at the end of the book you know
something bad is gonna happen because
as i said the last few pages like arthur
finds out from samuel daly that it's
like okay so every time the woman in
black is seen that means a child's gonna
die
now up to now it's always been a child
in the town
but arthur's been there for a few days
no kids have died it's
everything seems copacetic you know
samuel's like no you know no kids have
died not yet
and arthur's like well maybe the curse
is broken now that mrs drablo is gone
and
you know maybe she's not gonna like seek
vengeance anymore and um you know samuel
is like well yeah i hope so
but you know because a kid didn't die in
the town you know some bad shit's gonna
happen
and i should note too that unlike
the movie adaptations arthur is actually
telling this story like many years later
like he has um remarried he has like a
bunch of kids
so it's a really old school like
christmas
british ghost story because like i said
it's a very british tradition like to
tell ghost stories around christmas time
so that's how this is framed so like the
first few
pages of the book are arthur kips he's
like you know gearing up for christmas
without with his wife
and esme and all his kids and they're
all telling ghost stories and being all
like
jocular about them and like trying to
creep each other out and he gets like
all
annoyed about it and he's basically like
you guys don't even know like
that ghost shit's like it's not even
funny like i don't know why you're
telling them for amusement
he's like i had the worst he didn't tell
his family like i had the worst [ __ ]
experience with ghosts ever
but what he basically does is like i
guess them telling ghost stories like
reminded him
of like the worst thing that ever
happened to him back when he was younger
and so he's like i'm going to write all
this down but i don't want my family to
read it until after i'm dead
so that's kind of like the frame story
so that's kind of one thing that differs
between the book and the movie
adaptations is that you know that arthur
at least is not gonna die because he's
telling
this story from many years later
so you know but you know that something
bad's gonna happen right so what ends up
happening at the end of the
you know the old story is that arthur um
you know goes
he has like a nervous breakdown
essentially so he ends up having to stay
in the town for
a while just because he keeps flip
flipping out and everything
um and then his uh fiance comes to get
him stella
and they go back to london and
everything's fine they get married
um he gets a raise and they have a son
yeah you know where this is going
so basically the sun i believe it's only
like six months later
the kid's still pretty young and he goes
to the park
with his wife stella and uh
stella and the baby want a pony and trap
ride
and it don't go too well
that's what i'm saying again a very
bleak ending so
you know he sees the woman in black at
the very end and he's like oh [ __ ]
you know the woman in black has like
come to collect because apparently
when janet died she was so full of rage
that her child drowned in the
marsh that she's basically just gonna
take
everybody's kid that she can take as
vengeance
so that's what ends up happening at the
end of the book
he lives and actually goes on seemingly
to have like
a relatively happy life he marries again
he has children and stuff because that's
kind of where you're at at the beginning
of this and he's talking about what
happened in the past
now interestingly there have been
several uh adaptations of this
now one of the most famous was actually
they did a stage adaptation
and if i remember correctly the stage
adaptation of this
is the longest running play
on the west end well the second most i
think the first one is the mouse trap
but this this is the second longest
running play on the west end
so it just goes to show how popular
however green
these you know classic british ghost
stories are because that's
exactly what this is this is a very
classic it's very restrained
it even has like the christmas you know
frame of him like
telling oh well you want to read a
really scary story here's like this
really horrible ghost story that
happened to me like a long time ago
so it's just like you know dickens and
just like mr james and just like those
kind of things so susan hill
basically wanted to make something that
was just like a classic
english ghost story and that's exactly
what this is so the play
i don't know much about that because i
haven't seen it but i have seen the two
film adaptations
so in 1989 they made um like a made for
tv uh you know in the uk i think it was
itv maybe made it
and uh an adaptation of this which i
have seen it it's very good it's very
creepy
they changed a few things they changed
everyone's names which i'm not really
sure why like some of their first names
some of their last names i don't know
but whatever
and also in the end and then the end of
the film adaptation too
everybody dies like the whole like
arthur dies too so i thought that was
kind of interesting that they made it
that they made the ending like even
bleaker and like sadder than it was in
the book because
in the book yes his wife and son die
but you know the woman of black gets
them but he lives
and lives out a full life and you know
is able to finally recover and blah blah
even though
you know he's still like haunted by it
obviously but he goes on and still has
like kind of a happy life
whereas that really doesn't happen in
the film adaptation now they also made
an adaptation in 2012
um this one was starring daniel
radcliffe um this was also
quite good this one was interesting
because they really played
up the woman in black as like a
you know a portent of a child dying in
the town in the book
they don't really go a lot into that i
mean you don't really find
out that she is like a representation of
that until like the last few pages
i think the only other mention of it
it's like when he when he's at the
funeral like at the beginning of the
book
like the author mentions that there's
like a bunch of kids
like behind the fence like looking but
that's really the only mention there is
whereas the daniel radcliffe movie they
really
lean hard into every time the woman in
black gets seen
that means a child dies you know what i
mean so it's like a child dies like near
the beginning of the thing
and it's like kids just keep dying like
through the whole in fact if i remember
like the very beginning they had like
three little girls who were just like
having a tea party and then they just
say hey we're gonna like i'll jump out
the window
and like some of them are like drinking
poison or drinking lie or something like
that
so they really kind of lean hard into
like kids dying every time the woman in
black is seen
the book doesn't really do that like i
said that's that's something that you
don't find out until the very end
the book is very very subtle
it only it takes place only like over a
couple of days
there's not like a huge amount i mean
it's basically
it's told all from his point of view
because you know in the universe of the
book
he's writing down his ghost story you
know from many years ago so it's all you
know in first person
and he's basically just talking just
going through his days of like what's
happening how he's feeling like what
he's seeing what he's hearing
so it's kind but it's very restrained
it's not kind of like oh a big thing
jumped out of my face or oh this and
that and the other thing
it's all real subtle stuff it's kind of
stuff like i you know i saw the
woman like across the graveyard you know
i was in the house and i heard this
weird noise that turned out to be like a
rocking chair like in this locked up
room
you know i went back in the locked up
room later and before it was like really
neat with all the toys made and now it's
like all messed up like poltergeist
activity or whatever
so it's all that kind of stuff and
everything just kind of happens once
and as i said like no kids die um they
basically mentioned that mr jerome's kid
died last time the woman in black was
seen i don't remember if they said like
specifically when that was but it's been
a while
it's so i thought it was interesting i
guess because you know uh
you know hammer horror made the woman in
black
that came out in 2012 so that i think
they really wanted to amp
up the horror aspect of it so they had
like a whole bunch of kids like die in
the movie
and um at the end of the movie the
daniel radcliffe one from 2012
uh the whole family dies there as well
because in that one arthur he has a wife
that's already died
but he has so he has a son he's like a
single father but his son is like
six years old so i think they wanted to
give him a kid that was a little bit
older
so that that kid could be in danger you
know what i mean
and i think they also wanted to kill his
wife off before that happened
just because so they kind of switched
around the timeline somewhat
but i can see why they did that and then
at the end of the movie um
you know him and his kid die they get
hit by a train
um you know they see the woman in black
like as they're trying to like leave the
town on the train
it's a bleak ending but it's also kind
of a happy ending because they're
implying that
oh you know he now they're he's with his
wife because she died
like before the events of the movie and
you know now they're all together again
although i think there's an implication
too that that it's just the woman in
black like
looking like his wife i'm not really
sure if that's
what they were going for i mean i kind
of got that impression but i'm not
really sure
now they also made a sequel to that
movie which i think was called woman of
black 2 angel of death
i haven't seen that obviously it doesn't
have anything it's not an adaptation of
the book
and i'm not really sure if it's any good
i haven't really heard anybody talking
about it so
i'll probably check it out one of these
days because i really did like the
daniel radcliffe version
but if you see the movies first which i
did in a way i'm kind of bummed
that i like that i watched the movies
first because
i already knew like it had been a while
since i'd seen the movies but i already
i already knew like what the story was
or like where the story was going i i
already knew that it was like
this woman her kid had drowned in the
thing and
and she was like taking revenge on the
town and like killing off their kids or
or at least like acting as like hey your
kid's gonna die or whatever
um so i kind of already knew where it
was going but that said
i really really enjoyed like the the
imagery of this book like the way it's
written
it's just very it's just has this great
like moody
creepy like kind of atmosphere like the
way she describes
causeway like going out to the house and
you know how everything just looks like
this big like foggy
thing of gray and then there's just like
this house out there with these little
tumble down gravestones and i love
like real gothic imagery like that so
like that
i really really liked even though i knew
where the plot was going mostly although
the end kind of surprised
me because it's different than the
movies slightly but you know that so
like i said i wish i'd
read it first and then seen the movies
because if you see the movies first the
movies are a lot more
horror you know there's a lot more [ __ ]
going on in the movies than in the book
because the book is like i said it's
very restrained it's very subtle
because she was trying to do something
like you know like a classic
british ghost story like from you know
late 19th
early 20th century type of thing which i
think was like
massively successful i mean there's a
reason that this book has been adapted
so many times there's a reason that
this book is so you know popular there's
a reason
that so many people recommend it as
being super creepy because it really
like immerses you
in this whole atmosphere of like this
little tiny town it's just like covered
with fog and it's just like so creepy
and it's like everybody just has a
secret
no one wants to tell you anything and
there's just like this creepy woman
like you know kind of toodling around in
the background like every now with her
weird skeletal face and like her morning
clothes and everything
so you know as i said if you're if
you're looking for something that's like
slasher or something like that it's
nothing like that at all this is a very
restrained ghost story
but it's a really really good one um and
it's if you
if you want to read something that's
kind of like evocative
of you know your your old classic ghost
stories but is more
modern even though it's not set in the
modern era but is you know
written in more modern language i'll put
it that way
then i would definitely definitely
recommend it as i said the movie
adaptations are quite good as well
the british tv one is actually quite
good it's very
creepy i think it was actually written
the british one was written by nigel
neal
and i think he also did the stone
tape which was also like a made for tv
kind of like horror movie which is
actually really good i talked about it
on
my blog a couple of years ago um so yeah
but they're both definitely worth um
checking out and obviously the book is
worth checking out too
if you have not read it yet uh so yeah
the woman in black
susan hill check it out and that'll do
it for this discussion
and i'll see you on the next one bye